[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Barbara
how can we
help hi Ken hi Dr John how are you thank
you for how your good we're having fun
what's going on with you today um well
first I just want to appreciate you
saying Nevada right I gotta tell you
I've said it wrong enough to finally get
it right it's Nevada even though I want
to say Nevada it's
Nevada awesome so the reason I'm calling
in is
because um I have committed plenty of um
Financial infidelity trying to help my
father who's disabled um he has little
to no income and um it's becoming a
problem obviously in my marriage because
we're now in B step two we're wanting to
you know knock all this debt out but at
the same time feel kind of
emotionally I don't know tied like
wanting to help my father but like
wanting to stay faithful to my you know
my finances so what has happened up to
this point give give the good doctor
here uh a bit of a sample of what
Financial infidelity has looked like up
to this
moment so my fathers come to me for
loans um you know not we're not talking
like big numbers like thousands of
dollars or anything like that but you
know maybe in like the hundreds range um
but like we're my husband and I are kind
of like low income so it's it's a big
deal when we loan out you know a couple
hundred what's your combined income um
right now uh it's we're a one income
household and um for shy of 39,000 why
are you a one um income
household um so I'm a stayhome mom right
now but um I just uh I got I had a work
injury and so um I've been kind of stuck
at home you know what kind of work
injury so I hurt my back at
work um can can you get a job working
from
home uh I was I'm looking into it but um
the main thing is that like with my dad
it's kind of become a little bit of like
I don't I don't know if emotional
manipulation become kind of like a
strong n listen I just want to stop
right there 100% of this is on
you yes okay I agree so what your dad is
doing what he knows to do which is to
ask you for money and he gets it from
you and so if you cut that off or if you
say Hey Dad it's not a good time he's
going to use whatever tactics he knows
and if he was on the phone I would say
stop doing that but the fact that he
gets an exchange money comes from your
account to him he he plays no part in
that you give it to him for whatever
reason okay so whether he's manipulating
you being mean talk whatever you are
handing him the money and at the same
time you're choosing to lie to your
husband about
it you're absolutely right so I want you
to take full ownership this same
ownership as and the reason Ken's asking
you about what does this look like and
I'm asking you about working from home
is it's real easy to get into this well
I can't do this and I can't do this but
I have to do this and I just think
there's a big box of bull crap to most
all of that yeah you can get a work from
home job millions and millions and
millions of people have done it yeah in
fact her answer to your question you
asked her point blank can you and you
said Barbara we're not picking on you
but your response was well I'm looking
into that when the answer was yes or no
and the answer is yes unless the kids
are eating up all of your time but you
worked prior to the back injury so the
question becomes now how long before the
back is healed when does the doctor say
you can now resume whatever your PR
previous duties were the point we're
asking here is you've got to make some
changes number one we need more income
at this point in in Reno Nevada in 2023
with you have the ability to work at
home or in the office your choice
there's no way you guys should be making
39,000 gross that's separate issue from
you giving your dad money but either way
we've got to make some really clear
changes in our life and it's also easy
to get buried by shame you do one you
don't tell the truth one time and then
that's piles on to this and it piles on
to that and so what I want you to do is
to begin to think of yourself imagining
yourself standing up on your own two
feet and saying I'm taking control of
all of this now have you has your
husband asked you point blank where's
all this money and you're like I don't
know and you you've lied to him or you
have you just done this thing
quietly so um it I my husband and I
started talking about it a few months
ago maybe more than that um because
obviously like things started to get
tight and it was like oh well how come
we can't you know afford that and then
you know had to kind of complain about
it and so now we're kind of on you know
I've told them like I'm going to put my
foot down cuz you're absolutely right um
I the onus is on me like I'm the one
that needs to have the backbone to be
like you know I'm sorry Dad I can't and
that's true because we don't we don't
have the money but I do agree with you
guys I definitely need to um get a you
know a job from home um I'm not opposed
to that at all um
so he to answer your question my husband
is aware he's he you know we've I've
made we've made an agreement together
that I'm not going to fall back on that
I'm not going to you know feel
um uh what's the word like I I'm not
going to do that anymore Barbara one of
the things that you guys probably should
do is a budget if you guys done a an
every dollar budget using our world
class app or the point is a zerob based
budget where we're going to spend every
dollar on paper because this is an extra
layer of accountability if you're both
communicating on the budget then the
agreement that you just made or you
mentioned has more teeth have you guys
done this um yes so we have a budget um
we actually need to um plug back into
the dollar every dollar app yeah because
there's not a line item for Dad
anymore right or if there is or if there
is you agree we're gonna send 50 bucks a
month and that's what we've agreed on I
if my dad was disabled and could not eat
without support I would have a hard time
not helping okay yeah of course but I
would have to sit down and be honest
with my wife about it and not lie and
hide about it and maybe I can't send him
500 bucks like I want to but I can do 50
and I would recommend you and your
husband getting on a phone call with Dad
so you're both on the same page and say
Dad we've done a budget we can no longer
afford to support you we can do this or
we can't do anything and that's the way
it's going to be moving forward so
you're both on the same page Dad can't
pull anybody's heartstrings and then
y'all can get lined up and go forward
together but you got to get a job ASAP
create your free every dooll budget
today the simplest way to budget for
your life